We basically do quantitative
and qualitative research
in order to understand how people think.
Talia Wolf,
thank you so much for joining me
on 20 Minute Leaders.
Good morning.
Thank you so much for having me.
Chief optimizer at the Getuplift.
What does it mean to be an optimizer?
Well, we help brands,
high growth brands,
optimize their funnels in their websites.
So, essentially, turning more
of their traffic into customers,
leads, users and so on.
So, the idea is to leave the traffic as is
and basically optimize the website
whether if it's the copy,
the user experience,
the journey itself,
the visuals and so on.
And run A/B tests in order to see
what actually increases convergence.
So, it sounds exciting.
Conversions are incredibly challenging.
And I'm excited to learn more
about the space, about the challenges,
about the creative solutions around it.
But even more exciting than that
is jumping from a plane.
So, Talia, how do you get to do
a thousand jumps from an airplane?
How does that happen?
You have to be crazy.
No. I don't know.
I went to see a friend of mine
jumping out of a plane.
She was doing a course.
I saw it. And I'm like,
okay, yeah, this is cool.
And that was basically it.
Yeah. I've skydived.
I sure have skydive a lot in the US too.
So, in the area of California,
quite a bit, and where else, Chicago.
But why do a course?
I skydived twice or three times.
And you know,
it's an exhilarating journey.
I almost pee my pants every time
and I keep asking myself,
why did I do this to myself.
But then, I am always happy that I did.
But what motivates you to go
and do a real course
and be certified in that?
You know what,
it's probably the most amazing feeling
you can ever get.
And the best feeling for me
is that moment when you leave the plane.
It's not even the fall itself
when we're doing all these
elaborate cool things or flying a canopy.
It's actually that moment
when you are leaving the plane.
And what's cool about it is that
I mean, for me at least,
my brain's working 24 hours.
So, I'm constantly thinking and working
and constantly thinking about things.
And when you jump out of a plane,
there is pure two minutes of nothing.
And it's not just nothing like a void.
It's nothing, it's filled with calm.
It's just amazing.
And of course, it's the adrenaline
and all the fun and jumping with friends
and competitions and all that.
But the calm, the I'm not thinking
about anything right now
except to this moment.
Do you understand the absurdity
of how you're describing
that calm feeling
of jumping out of an airplane,
falling at an acceleration
of 10 meters per second?
And you're saying, but it's the calm,
it's two minutes of calmness.
So, anybody that's listening to this
that hasn't jumped off of a plane,
I mean, I can testify somewhat,
I think you're being
completely delusional,
that it's a calm experience.
And I scream my heart out the whole time.
But I'm sure that, hopefully,
I'll get to that point one day.
I'll meditate here on the couch
in the meantime.
But thank you for sharing.
Talia, why is conversion so hard?
And what is conversion, first of all,
to whoever doesn't necessarily
really grasp it?
All right.
So, essentially when
you start a business,
whether if it's an e-commerce business
or maybe it's a SaaS product,
you're trying to get conversions,
you're trying to get more sales.
Maybe even if you're a consultant,
you're trying to get leads.
If you're a SaaS company,
then you're trying
to get users and people
to sign up for a free trial
or schedule a demo.
Those aren't conversions.
That's what your company decides on.
And you're driving traffic.
You're spending a ton of money in ads
on Google, on Facebook or doing SEO
or content writing in order to drive
as many people as possible
to your website or to your landing pages
in order to convert people into leads
or into sign ups and so on.
And the thing is that,
for many, many years,
most companies spent a lot of money
on driving that traffic to the website,
but didn't think about
what happens when people
actually arrive on the website.
How do you convince people to sign up.
And what's really interesting is that,
these days we live in a world
where we see 40,000 messages a day.
I mean, everyone's targeting us.
Everyone's trying to get our attention.
So, how do you actually
stand out in that crowd
and get your prospect to say,
yes, this company looks interesting
and I'm not going to go
and look at the five other competitors.
And that's conversion optimization.
It's about optimizing the experience
that people go for
when they get your website and funnel
so that you can get more conversions.
And so, what are the main attributes
that would make me
as a consumer, first of all,
and before we even talk about
the marketing, me as a consumer,
what are some of the main
rationalizations
that I go through,
or what is the behavior that I exhibit
as I'm being targeted
that would maybe enforce me
to go in one direction or another?
Because I think, that is the foundation
of this whole issue. Right?
What motivates me.
I worked with Dan Ariely quite a bit
with irrational lives.
And so, thinking about consumer behavior
has been a lifelong passion.
But I'm excited to hear your take
on from conversion standpoint.
100%.
So, most times when you think about
optimizing for conversion, people think,
okay, I'll make a button bigger
or I'll change the headline
and that's going to work.
But actually,
the process that we've developed,
the methodology that I develop
is called emotional targeting.
And it's exactly based
on everything that Dan Ariely does.
It's all about understanding
how people make decisions.
When you understand
how people make decisions,
the real intent,
the different psychological triggers
and biases that we have in our brain,
it's easier for you to understand
what kind of experience
someone needs to go through
in order to convert.
It's never going to be the same.
But you have different target audiences
that act in different ways.
So, if you can understand the pains,
the challenges, the different roadblocks
that people are going through,
and most importantly,
the desired outcome,
what is that emotional feeling
that people are looking for.
And I'll give you an example.
Please.
You're not buying a shirt.
You're buying self-esteem.
You're not buying insurance.
Basically you're not buying
a piece of paper for insurance.
You're buying security.
You're buying peace of mind.
And that is basically
the difference between
just changing an element on the page
and hoping that it will get more sign ups
versus actually thinking about
what is that emotional drive.
What is the emotional intent
behind a decision and then
creating an experience for that.
So, it just requires a lot of
research and understanding intent
on how people make decisions,
just like you mentioned.
Right.
How do you get started
even researching this?
So, becoming somewhat of an expert
in this idea of rationality?
Because these analogies
that you just made,
you're not buying a T-shirt,
you're buying self-esteem,
you're not buying insurance
as a piece of paper,
you're buying comfort and peace of mind.
It's a process.
Not ,you know,
it's not like the average person
can just come and say,
okay, I'm understanding how people think.
How do you get started with that?
Yeah.
Well, it's funny because
when I started out
with conversion optimization,
I tried the other thing.
I tried reading blog post
and following best practices
and asking people for their opinion.
And that tanked.
Like literally I lost
a hundred thousand dollar client
because of that.
Really? Wow.
Well, that's how, you know,
when you get started,
you try different things and you fail.
And that's great.
That's the life of the entrepreneur.
But thanks to those fails
and to trying these things
and that treadmill of just kind of,
it's not even a treadmill.
It's a hamster wheel.
You keep going over and over
trying the same things that don't work.
So, what I did is
I basically started researching
how people make decisions in life.
And I understood that what was missing
was that psychology part of it.
So, you can't just wake up and say,
oh, okay, I know how people think.
You have to do a methodological research.
So we do surveys,
and we use heat maps,
and we do interviews,
and we use eye tracking
and we use data from Google Analytics.
And we basically do quantitative
and qualitative research
in order to understand
how people think.
Now, what's good and what's on my side
is A/B testing.
Because I can come and say,
I think the emotional drivers are social,
let's say it's social image.
I want social image
as a psychological trigger,
which basically means that we want,
we care about
what other people think about us.
On the other side,
you could have self image, which is,
I want to feel better about myself.
But let's say
that we've chosen social image.
That's what we want to test.
So, I'll create a variation
that focuses on social image,
on the outcome that is social image
and how other people will feel about you.
And you test it,
and you see the data that comes in
and you see if it works
and if it doesn't.
And even if it doesn't,
you've still learn something.
So, it's really just about research
and testing all the time.
That makes a lot of sense.
So, walk me through the process.
You're getting a new client
and you're starting to work.
And obviously,
I think one of the impressive things here
is that you have to context
which all the time between
different types of clients.
Right?
One time, it's a social image.
And other time, it's a different trigger
or a cognitive bias
that you are trying to invoke.
And so, what is the process
that you and your team have to go through
in order to, you know, first of all,
optimize yourself towards that problem
and then the process with that company
of actually finding
a solution that satisfies?
Yeah. That's a great question.
Because there's also biases
that we live in.
Even we go to analyze things,
we have our own biases and the things
that we think are going to work.
One of the things that we do is,
when we start working with a new client
is we split the work between
different people in the teams.
So, for example,
if we do an audit on a website,
then a lot of it
includes running surveys,
interviews,
something called review, mining,
competitor analysis, work all that stuff.
But we get different people doing it.
And then we compare out notes
and see if we reach the same conclusions
or similar conclusions.
So, it's a process
that really begins with people
and ends with people.
And I can tell you that
with various companies
and clients that we've worked with,
we've found that many times
without talking to each other
throughout the process,
we each come with our own conclusions
that turn out to be very similar.
And if they're not,
then we'll propose two different tests.
So, it's a very cool way
to go about the research and to say,
okay, here's what we're looking.
Here's what we're seeing on the website.
We're also using quantitative data
so we know what's going on.
We know how people are behaving
on the website,
now we have to basically attach
the psychological part to it.
So, it's search and testing all the time.
Sure.
And how early
do usually work with the companies?
Are these companies that are already huge
and they have thousands
of potential customers?
Or are these also startups that are just
trying to get their product market fit
and understanding what is the product
that we should be aiming for,
given a target audience
that we believe in?
Yeah.
So, for our client work,
we usually work with companies
that have a minimum
of three hundred conversions a month.
And we do that because
in order to run a viable test
as a statistically significant test,
we need to have about
150 conversions per variation.
So, that is the best fit.
So, it's usually
more high growth companies.
However, we do have
courses and when we do
the courses and the trainings,
they are for more of the entrepreneurs
and startups that are
just getting started
and want to learn how to do these things
themselves so they can set themselves
up for success.
And then later, hopefully,
when they get to that stage,
they can always hire us
in order to take them to the next level.
Right. That makes a lot of sense.
So, what are some things that
early stage companies,
young entrepreneurs can already do
as they're building their product,
as they're gaining conversions
in order to get into this
conversion optimization mindset?
Because obviously,
it's great to be able to come in
and have Getuplift come
and help when you're in hypergrowth.
But it sounds to me like this
is almost like a strategy
or a talent that you want to improve on,
on every step of the journey
as the leader in the company?
100%.
You know, what's really cool is that
being that small startup
that just getting started,
even if it's in a very crowded industry,
gives you a lot of advantage.
And the advantage is that you are leaner
and you can move fast
and you can do your research,
which a lot of companies now
that are huge and are very big
and very well known
don't have the capacity or time to do
or even the people to do it.
And even they did imply start doing it,
it would take them a whole year.
You, as a startup or a founder,
can already start running
those researchers in terms of
surveying your potential customers,
doing interviews,
doing the jobs to be done,
framework of Google,
that it's a super important
framework to do.
You could be interviewing people.
You could be doing review mining.
You can really go deep.
And what's really cool about this process
is that you end up finding
your unique selling proposition.
And that unique selling proposition
is going to help you actually stand out
in front of all those competitors
and the big companies in the industry.
So, you can get started immediately
by going back to basics.
And before you start planning
any landing page,
any ad or even your website,
first, do the research
in order to understand
who your customer is,
what their desired outcomes are,
what are their pains and concerns.
And make sure that everything
that you create is about the customer.
It's about them and their desired outcome.
Right.
I was actually introduced to getting
the job that needs to be done
back at the venture capital class
at Stanford.
But I would love for you
to tell us a little
bit about this concept
and about this this
mentality as a founder
and entrepreneur, thinking about what is
the job that needs to be done
with the customer at the forefront.
What is that framework?
Yeah. I mean, at the end of the day,
what you're trying to figure out is
what is the job that your prospect
is trying to get done with your solution.
Right.
And I think that many times people think,
oh, you know, if they're using a,
let's say they're using Slack,
they're trying to get work done,
or Trello, they're trying
to manage the project.
But it's rarely that simple.
It's not that they're trying
to manage a project.
It's that they're trying
to maybe save time,
maybe reduce friction within the company.
Maybe they're trying to,
essentially what they're doing is
they're trying to get to an end result.
That is the desired outcome
I keep talking about.
The easiest way to explain this is that
if you are a parent
and you are now thinking
about buying a product for your child.
So, maybe it's a toy,
maybe it's something
that they need to build,
or maybe you're planning
a birthday party for your child.
There's a lot of things
that come into place here.
It's not just about the act of,
here, I now have plates for the party,
or I now have a toy to give to this kid.
It's more about that desired outcome
and what's going to happen at the end.
My kid is going to be happy,
or other parents are going to know
that I am a great parent,
or I'm going to feel great
about my parenting skills.
So, it's always about that job
that people are trying to get done.
And there's a whole framework
that really helps you.
What's good about this specific framework
is just that it takes you away
from the personas,
which is 90% made up.
And then it takes you into a real way
to framework and understand
who exactly is your customer,
what are they trying to get done
and how you should be speaking to them.
Right.
That makes a lot of sense.
Talia, why are you so excited about this?
Why are you so excited about
conversion optimization?
Obviously, I think,
it's an exhilarating journey
seeing every day, different client
or every few weeks a different client,
and solving a different problem
and seeing that impact.
But where's that passion come from?
It's funny that you ask this
because I used to run
a conversion optimization agency
and we sold the agency
and I joined a startup company.
And I worked in this startup company
as a CMO for about,
I don't know, eight months.
And the whole eight months,
all I wanted to do
was conversion optimization.
And I ended up leaving that company
and going back to starting my own
consulting business
for conversion optimization.
So, I think, first of all,
I found my passion.
And I really do love what I do.
I love trying to understand people
and how they make decisions.
And most of all,
I love helping my clients.
I just really enjoy it
and going on that journey with them.
So, I'm just really passionate
about what I do.
And how much of that would you say
of your time you spend
on the psychological side
versus the quantitative side
that you're getting?
And when I say the quantitative,
I mean the Google Analytics
and the A/B testing
with the landing pages
and the messaging
versus sitting down and saying,
okay, let's figure out
what is this cognitive bias
that we're invoking,
what are the emotions
that our user is experiencing,
you're probably also encouraged doing
a lot of user interviews
and customer interviews
to understand them.
But which part
do you spend more time on usually?
It depends.
Mostly what happens is
we always start with quantitative.
So, we'll start with Google Analytics
and Heat Maps in order to understand
where the problem is
and what needs fixing.
And then we'll use qualitative data
in order to answer how to fix that.
So, Google Analytics
is a great tool to use
in order to understand, like,
hey, there is a problem on this page
or there's a problem in this funnel.
But it doesn't tell you
why that problem is happening.
So, then we'll use qualitative data
in order to answer that question
and figure out,
okay, so we know there's a problem
on the pricing page,
or we know there's a problem in checkout.
Or we know there's a problem
on the home page,
how do we fix that.
What is the problem,
and identifying it and then solving it.
So, most of the time, the biggest part
is the qualitative research
because it takes more time.
And it's about solving a problem.
The quantitative is more of a way
of informing ourselves and understanding
what needs to be fixed.
Right. That makes a lot of sense.
By the way,
do you have any interesting case study
or any specific
occurrence with an insight
as to something that surprised you
along the journey
that you were working with the client,
you were trying to solve something
with conversion and then you realized
that it was something like really weird,
obscure that without that research,
you were necessarily fine?
You know,
one of my recent
tests, I worked with
social media marketing examiner,
socia lmedia examiner.
They've got the social media examiner
which is the blog
and the social media marketing world,
which is that conference.
So, SME, which is social media examiner,
one of the biggest blogs
in the world for social media,
they hired us in order to help them
sell more tickets for their conference
in San Diego.
And when I looked at their landing page,
it wasn't actually
a classic landing page.
It's a blog post. It's essentially
a five thousand word blog post.
Wow.
And I'm looking at it.
And I kept thinking,
we need to optimize this.
We need a classic landing page.
We need to have a header, have this,
have real call to action buttons.
And in the end,
when we did our research,
we realized that the actual people
who are coming to this page
don't need that at all.
What they actually need
is to have this specific blog.
And what we did, which is funny,
is that after doing this research,
we understood that what was missing
was even more content.
So, we added a whole section about
the pains that they're going through,
all the stuff that isn't
working for them,
the pains, the roadblocks,
the challenges and basically painted
the new picture that could be.
And we actually by just adding more copy
to the website, to that page,
we actually got a 15% increase in sales.
So, it's really cool to see that
it's not always the stuff
that you think it's going to be
and the stuff that's most like
what everyone else is doing.
Because any other conference you look at
have a really cool,
classic looking landing page,
and this is very different.
That's fascinating.
Talia, thank you so much for coming
and for inspiring me these 20 minutes.
Before we leave,
I have to ask you the hardest
and most important question,
which is three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
Okay. I'm going to say passionate,
because you can hear much of them.
I'm going to say dedicated.
And I am going to say geek.
I love that.
Passionate, dedicated and geek.
Talia, thank you very, very much.
This is wonderful.
Stay safe and stay healthy.
Same to you.
Thank you for having me.